Bielorrusia es el prototipo perfecto de país
que nunca dejó atrás el esquema de poder
del antiguo imperio comunista.
De esta forma, siguiendo el mejor patrón
de las películas de Hollywood cuándo hablan
de las repúblicas ex soviéticas, es un país
relativamente pobre dirigido con mano de hierro
por un estrafalario tirano.
Ojo, lo de tirano no lo decimos nosotros.
Os recordamos que es algo de lo que se jacta
el mismo.
C1("El gobierno autoritario es algo propio
de mí.
Siempre lo he admitido”.
“Es mejor ser dictador que ser gay”
–Alexander Lukashenko, Presidente de Bielorrusia)
Y, ojo que hablamos de un dictador que ante
la crisis de inflación que vive el mundo
no se le ha ocurrido nada mejor que prohibir
por ley la inflación.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
(La inflación prohibida en Bielorrusia)
(Bielorrusia prohíbe los aumentos de los
precios al consumidor en un intento por domar
la inflación)
En este vídeo no vamos a contaros porque
intentar prohibir la inflación supone desde
el punto de vista económico un gigantesco
error.
Eso se lo dejamos a VisualEconomik.
Claro que esta no es la única medida tomada
por este tirano para contener los precios.
¿Habéis oído hablar de la movilización
general para la recogida de patatas?
Pues fijaos.
(Bielorrusia: Lukashenko pide movilizar a
los niños para cosechar patatas y manzanas.)
Empezó con los niños y terminó metiendo
en el saco a medio país.
Sea como sea, esta no es la razón por la
que Bielorrusia protagoniza este vídeo.
Lo cierto es que más allá de su peculiar
política económica en los últimos tiempos
, Lukashenko está acaparando la atención
internacional.
Y lo está haciendo, ni más ni menos, que
por ser el país que más apoya la terrible
invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Incluso se está especulando con que, finalmente,
Bielorrusia pueda sumarse a la ofensiva contra
Ucrania.
En junio el gobierno del conocido como último
dictador de Europa anunció la creación del
Comando Operativo del Sur, una fuerza de combate
que se desplegará en la frontera con Ucrania.
También anunció la ampliación del ejército
y, más recientemente, a comienzos de octubre
confirmó que se creará un contingente militar
conjunto con Rusia.
En principio esto supondrá la llegada al
país de miles de soldados del país de los
zares..
Según el régimen de Lukashenko se ha tomado
esta decisión para proteger sus fronteras.
C2("Hacemos hincapié una vez más en que
las tareas del grupo de fuerza regional son
puramente defensivas.
Y todas las actividades llevadas a cabo en
este momento tienen como objetivo proporcionar
una respuesta suficiente a las acciones cerca
de nuestras fronteras" Viktor Khrenin, Ministro
de Defensa de Bielorrusia.)
Por supuesto, nadie se lo ha creído.
El propio presidente Ucraniano Volodymyr Zelensky
hizo saltar las alarmas durante la siguiente
sesión del G7 y propuso enviar equipos de
Naciones Unidas a la frontera entre Ucrania
y Bielorrusia para evitar una nueva escalada
en el conflicto.
C3("En la frontera entre Ucrania y Bielorrusia,
podemos colocar una misión de observadores
internacionales para monitorear la situación
de seguridad.
Nuestros diplomáticos pueden elaborar el
formato.
Te pido, a nivel del G7, que apoyes esta iniciativa".
Volodymyr Zelenskiy, Presidente de Ucrania)
Esto, por supuesto, no ocurrirá, porque como
todos sabemos a la hora de la verdad y más
allá de la política de los gestos y las
declaraciones la ONU no vale para gran cosa.
El caso es que como nadie se cree a Lukashenko
y los movimientos militares en Rusia y Bielorrusia
no dejan de sucederse al tiempo que los rusos
están perdiendo la guerra, ha surgido por
todas partes una pregunta: ¿Hasta qué punto
está Bielorrusia pensando en unirse a la
ofensiva rusa contra Ucrania?
¿Para qué van a utilizar exactamente esa
especie de ejército conjunto que han anunciado?
¿Qué podría suponer esto para el ejército
ucraniano?
En este vídeo te vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas, pero antes tenemos otra cuestión
que responder: ¿por qué demonios Lukashenko
sigue apoyando a Putin?
Atentos.
[Por cierto, stop,stop.
Te hago una pregunta que quizás nunca te
has hecho pero que seguro te va a interesar:
¿Cuánta riqueza per cápita acumulada hay
en todo el mundo?
Es decir, cómo de ricos somos realmente y
como ranquea tu país en este particular ranking.
Pues bien, según un estudio de la consultora
McKinsey la riqueza mundial asciende ni más
ni menos que a unos 65.800 dólares por cabeza.
La pregunta es, ¿Has acertado?
Y ahora qué sabemos cual es la cifra nos
surgen muchos más preguntas:, ¿Cómo se
distribuye y cómo se invierte toda esta enorme
riqueza?¿Cómo está evolucionando?
¿En qué países crece más?
Pues si quieres conocer todas las respuestas
no te pierdas el último vídeo de Si lo Hubiera
Sabido, el canal financiero de Mutuactivos
con el que participamos.
Os dejo el enlace por aquí abajo.]
Dicho esto, ahora sí, vayamos con el último
dictador de Europa.
T1(DE LA DESOBEDIENCIA A LA SUMISIÓN)
Alexander Lukashenko lleva gobernando este
país desde 1994.
Durante este tiempo su régimen se ha transformado,
ha pasado de ser un gobierno autoritario más
o menos suave a una autocracia cada vez más
corrupta y represiva.
Una dictadura que mantiene encarcelados a
más de 1.300 presos políticos y que ha convertido
al país en un desierto de alternativas políticas
a pesar de ser un régimen terriblemente impopular
en el país.
Por supuesto, por el camino la libertad de
prensa ha desaparecido por completo.
Y con un PIB de poco más de 7.000 dólares
per cápita, uno de los más bajos de toda
Europa, se estima que apenas el 25% de la
población apoya o simpatiza con este gobierno.
Hablamos sobre todo de pensionistas, burócratas
y miembros de los equipos de seguridad.
Por supuesto lo que no consigue con apoyo
popular el gobierno lo consigue con la fuerza
de las pistolas, las porras y las esposas.
Lo que en cierta forma se asemeja mucho a
la situación política que vive la Madre
Rusia.
Y hablando de Rusia, aunque ahora Putin y
Lukashenko parezcan casi hermanos de sangre
y socios inquebrantables, lo cierto es que
no siempre se han llevado tan bien.
(En 1999 el dictador bielorruso firmó un
acuerdo con el presidente ruso Boris Yeltsin
para crear una unión política y económica
total entre los dos países.
La idea era crear una entidad supranacional
que con el tiempo terminará siendo responsable
de la política económica, la política exterior
y la defensa.
Incluso se especuló que con el tiempo los
países terminarían teniendo una moneda común,
tribunales comunes e incluso un parlamento
único.
Lo que resulta más sorprendente de todo es
que todo apunta a que en aquel momento el
líder bielorrusio pensó que él mismo llegaría
a dirigir este megabloque.
Es decir, la jugada que tenía en mente Lukashenko
era algo así como una especie de OPA dónde
el pequeño se comía al grande.
Su idea es que Bielorrusia terminará controlando
toda Rusia.)
Sin embargo con la llegada de Putin al poder
esos planes se fueron al garete.
Y la OPA bielorrusa se dio la vuelta.
De repente el acuerdo se convirtió en algo
así como una puerta a la anexión de este
país por parte de Rusia.
Y por ese motivo Lukashenko frenó en seco
todo el proceso.
Y no solo eso.
Tras la anexión rusa de Crimea, Bielorrusia
que parecía alineada con Moscú empezó a
verle las orejas al lobo.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué hizo entonces el
último dictador de Europa?
Pues, básicamente, querer jugársela a Moscú
estrechando lazos con Occidente.
De hecho ni siquiera reconoció a Crimea como
parte de Rusia y las relaciones se volvieron
cada vez más tensas…
Hasta el año 2020.
En 2020 hubo elecciones, unas elecciones amañadas
que Lukashenko, por supuesto, ganó con el
80% de los votos.
Pero en esta ocasión las cosas no se iban
a quedar así.
La indignación popular se traduce en unas
revueltas enormes que apunto estuvieron de
tumbar al dictador.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué pensáis que ocurrió?
Pues…
Que Putin se convirtió en el salvavidas del
tirano bielorruso: envió propagandistas,
equipos de seguridad, dinero y finalmente
incluso confirmó que intervendría militarmente.
Es decir que mandaría a los tanques para
apoyar a su nuevo amigo.
Porque, por supuesto, todo este apoyo no fue
a cambio de nada.
A partir de ese momento Lukashenko se convertiría
en un títere de Moscú y los planes para
la integración progresiva de ambos países
se volverían a poner sobre la mesa.
Y la pregunta es, ¿por qué demonios le interesa
tanto al Kremlin esté país?
Pues..
Esta es la razón.
(Rusia ha intentado hacer crecer sus vínculos
políticos, económicos y militares con Bielorrusia
desde los años 90.
Sin embargo, este esfuerzo se ha multiplicado
desde el 2020.
Son 3 las razones que explican tanto interés
y que esté sea un asunto absolutamente estratégico
para el Kremlin:
Primero: Bielorrusia era importante para la
economía rusa porque por este país pasaba
más del 20% de todas las exportaciones rusas
de gas a Europa.
En segundo lugar, este país es el camino
más corto para llegar al Óblast de Kaliningrado
y llegado el caso permitiría cortar el corredor
de Suwalki, una estrecha franja de tierra
en la frontera polaco-lituana que podría
impedir el paso de fuerzas de la OTAN hacía
los países bálticos.
Y tercero por la propia obsesión de Putin
de restablecer la grandeza de Rusia.
Esencialmente el mismo motivo que lo ha empujado
a la guerra de Ucrania.)
¿Y qué mejor tanto para Putin que ampliar
la madre Rusia y restablecer la grandeza de
un nuevo imperio?
Ya veis que una vez más las casualidades
no existen.
Para colmo las sanciones internacionales han
hecho que la dependencia de Bielorrsua con
Rusia se multiplique.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, Putin no ha tenido
ningún problema en dar un montón de préstamos
para sostener a su nuevo lacayo.
Y, amigos, amigas, eso es exactamente lo que
explica que tras la despiadada invasión rusa
de Ucrania nos hayamos encontrado con declaraciones
como estas:
("Aquellos que nos reprochan, ¿no sabían
que tenemos la alianza más cercana con la
Federación Rusa?
Con ellos estamos construyendo un estado único,
poderoso e independiente: el Estado de la
Unión.
Hemos estado y estaremos juntos con la Rusia
fraterna.
Nuestra participación en la "operación especial"
fue decidida por mí hace mucho tiempo".
–Alexander Lukashenko, Presidente de Bielorrusia)
Ahora bien, pese a ello, el dictador ha ejecutado
un meticuloso plan de equilibrio durante la
guerra.
Por un lado permitió que antes de la invasión
30.000 soldados rusos se desplegaran en el
país.
Estas fueron las tropas que el día 24 de
febrero se lanzaron sobre Kiev.
También permitió que Rusia utilizará su
país para llevar a cabo un lanzamiento masivo
de misiles contra Ucrania.
Incluso cuatro días después de la invasión
Lukashenko revocó la neutralidad constitucional
de su país lo que ahora le permite a Rusia
estacionar tropas permanentes, incluyendo
armas nucleares.
¿Recordáis lo del títere de Putin?
Pues, eso.
Sin embargo, lo que no hizo Bielorrusia fue
unirse directamente a la guerra.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué se han disparado
los rumores acerca de que eso puede cambiar
próximamente?
¿Significa la creación del contingente militar
conjunto que Bielorrusia está a punto de
cambiar esa postura y sumarse a la guerra?
¿De ser así a qué se enfrentaría exactamente
Ucrania?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(TAMBORES DE GUERRA)
Durante la Guerra Fría, este territorio fue
muy importante para la Unión Soviética.
Las tropas estacionadas en la República Socialista
Soviética de Bielorrusia tenían la misión
de ser la punta de lanza del ejército rojo
en caso de que estallará el conflicto con
Occidente.
Por eso justo aquí se podían encontrar gran
parte de los equipos militares más modernos
del pacto de Varsovia, incluyendo una cuarta
parte de todos los misiles balísticos intercontinentales
soviéticos.
Sin embargo, tras la caída de la URSS la
situación cambió por completo.
Hoy el ejército bielorruso es ridículamente
pequeño y terriblemente anticuado.
Casi todos sus equipos tienen décadas de
antigüedad y proceden del ejército soviético.
De hecho, este es uno de los pocos países
que gastan más en seguridad interna que en
sus fuerzas armadas.Es decir, que no hablamos
de una dictadura militar, sino sobre todo
de una dictadura policial.
Ahí es dónde el régimen ha concentrado
casi todos sus recursos.
Porque el presupuesto militar apenas supone
en torno al 1% del PIB, unos 700 millones
de dólares anuales, a pesar de haber crecido
durante los últimos años.
Y eso no es todo, casi todo va a parar a gasto
corriente.
La inversión en compra de armas y equipos
militares es minúscula: para que os hagáis
una idea, entre los años 2014 y 2019 el país
apenas destinó 898 millones de dólares a
esta cuestión.
Una media anual de 180 millones, incluyendo
la corrupción.
El caso es que está falta de financiación
explica que el ejército bielorruso esté
formado por apenas unos 50.000 soldados.
Y eso no es todo, de estas tropas se estima
que sólo 17.000 estarían actualmente entrenados
y preparados para el despliegue.
Y eso siendo generosos.
Muchas fuentes reducen aún más esta estimación,
a una horquilla de entre 6.000 y 10.000 efectivos.
Para colmo Bielorrusia le ha entregado mucho
material a Rusia.
(“No tenemos las tropas ni el hardware militar.
Ya se ha entregado mucho hardware a la federación
rusa.
Hay pocas tropas listas para el combate, como
máximo unas 7.000, y no están listas para
una operación de asalto".
Franak Viačorka, asesor principal de la líder
de la oposición bielorrusa Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya)
Pero ojo que la falta de tropas no es el único
dato llamativo.
Por ejemplo se calcula que la fuerza aérea
apenas cuenta con 24 aviones con capacidad
de combate y que el ejército sólo podría
contar con unos 200 viejos tanques soviéticos
T-72.
(Lo que sí tienen, como medida disuasoria
es una reserva supuestamente de más de 290.000
personas.
Pero, la verdad, nadie da un duro porque tengan
el equipamiento y el entrenamiento mínimo
para llegar a ser de alguna utilidad en esta
guerra.
Luego tienen bastante equipamiento almacenado,
pero habría que ver en qué estado…
Después de ver el desastre ruso en Ucrania
no parece que se pueda esperar gran cosa de
Bielorrusia.)
Pero, un momento, entonces, ¿Por qué demonios
se hablá tanto de Bielorrusia?
¿A qué vienen tantos rumores y esa especie
de juego militar que se traen últimamente
entre Moscú y Minsk?
Pues bien, podemos encontrar 3 posibles respuestas:
En primer lugar, los soldados rusos y bielorrusos
que se están desplegando, otra vez, en la
frontera con Ucrania podrían tener el objetivo
de obligar a Kiev a trasladar parte de sus
efectivos a esta zona para prevenir un posible
nuevo ataque.
Esto podría reducir algo la enorme presión
que los rusos están sufriendo en el este
y en el sur de Ucrania.
Dónde cómo sabéis las tropas ucranianas
están logrando importantes avances.
Incluso hay quien apunta a que de seguir empeorando
las cosas, Moscú podría intentar un nuevo
asalto sobre Kiev, aunque sólo fuera para
forzar una negociación o desgastar a las
fuerzas ucranianas.
En segundo lugar, las tropas bielorrusas podrían
utilizarse para defender la retaguardia o
las redes de suministro, de tal forma que
Rusia pueda enviar más unidades al frente
al tiempo que sigue utilizando el suelo bielorruso
para ataques con misiles.
Y en tercer lugar, puede que lo esté pasando
sea exactamente lo contrario.
Que todos estos anuncios simplemente se terminen
traduciendo en la “donación” de los equipos
que tiene Bielorrusia.
De hecho se están viendo muchos traslados
de material como tanques y toneladas de munición
desde los almacenes bielorrusos hacia el frente,
lo que parece incompatible con buscar una
movilización militar en el país.
C6("Los líderes militares están tratando
de calmar a las tropas diciendo que no entrarán
en la guerra, ya que las tropas están muy
preocupadas por ver el éxito de los ucranianos.
Nadie quiere luchar por Putin".
Franak Viačorka, asesor principal de la líder
de la oposición bielorrusa Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya)
De hecho, la entrada de Bielorrusia en la
guerra podría ser contraproducente.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque por un lado podría terminar haciendo
que Washington le dé a Ucrania lanzacohetes
de largo alcance.
Por otro lado, podría poner a Lukashenko
contra las cuerdas.
Pensad que la guerra es tremendamente impopular
en Bielorrusia.
Según las encuestas menos del 10% de la población
apoya participar en la guerra.
De hecho, las operaciones de sabotaje contra
el ejército ruso han sido frecuentes e, incluso,
el viceministro de defensa llegó a dimitir
como protesta al apoyo a Rusia.
C7("Por supuesto que Putin tiene mucha influencia.
Pero no puede obligar a Lukashenko a suicidarse
políticamente".
Artyom Shraibman, analista político bielorruso)
Ya lo veis, Bielorrusia tiene poco que aportar
más allá de viejos equipos que a saber en
qué estado se encuentran.
Claro que si esta guerra se está caracterizando
por algo, es por la falta de racionalidad
de Moscú.
Y eso podría llegar a contagiar a sus compinches.
Sea como sea lo que está claro es que el
régimen de Lukashenko ha sido cómplice de
una inhumana y cruel ola de violencia y terror.
Y por eso su régimen tiene que estar en la
diana de todas las sanciones internacionales.
Pero dicho esto, turno para ti: ¿Creés que
finalmente veremos a Bielorrusia declarando
la guerra a Ucrania?
¿Es esta la penúltima bala que se guarda
Moscú para intentar revertir la derrota que
está sufriendo?
¿Cómo crees que evolucionará el conflicto?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Échale también un vistazo a VisualEconomik
y a Si lo Hubiera Sabido.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.